hello everyone and welcome to this panel
discussion on privacy pacific machine
learning at microsoft research summit
2021 i am shruti topley a senior
researcher in the confidential computing
team at microsoft research cambridge and
today joining us are prominent privacy
and security researchers from different
parts of the world i am delighted to
introduce our panel members divya gupta
divya is a senior researcher at
microsoft research india and her
research interest in cryptography and
its applications in security and privacy
currently divya's work at msr focuses on
secured multiparty computation and
blockchains and in particular making
cryptography practical usable and
performant she completed her phd at
university of california at los angeles
and her phd dissertation was recognized
by the dissertation fellowship and
dimitra's character's dissertation award
given for outstanding work in
engineering sciences medicine and
natural sciences
thank you divya for joining us
next we have aliya ariminko who is a
senior lecturer at the university
of melbourne that she joined in 2020 and
prior to that she was principal
researcher at microsoft research in
cambridge uk where she started as a
postdoctoral researcher in 2014.
her research interests include data
privacy integrity and security issues
that emerged in cloud computing
environment and machine learning
applications
she has held two research grants from
facebook and is currently a
co-investigator on an osmori grant olya
received her phd degree from brown
university in 2013. thank you alia for
participating in this panel discussion
and finally we have raza shokri who is
the nus presidential young professor of
computer science his research focuses on
data privacy and trustworthy machine
learning
reza is the recipient of the ieee
security and privacy test of time award
2021 for his paper on quantifying
location privacy he received the casper
burden award for outstanding research in
privacy and technologies in 2018 for his
work on analyzing the privacy risks of
machine learning
models
he received the early nus career award
2019 vmware early career faculty award
2021 and intel faculty research award
2021.
raza has obtained his phd from epfl
thank you so much reza for agreeing to
be a part of this panel discussion
now i would like to all of us start
having this exciting discussion we have
three interesting questions lined up and
without further ado i'll start with the
first question
what according to you are the current
capabilities of privacy techniques such
as trusted execution environments
homophobic encryption multi-party
computation differential privacy for
privacy preserving machine learning
and what do you think are still the gaps
and limitations that remain
divya i could like to start with you
what are your thoughts
uh excellent question shruti so um let
me start by describing the problem of
secure inference which is probably the
one of the most extensively studied
problem in privacy preserving machine
learning
in this scenario let's say there's a
model owner say a hospital or some
pharma company who has some pre-trained
machine learning model and on the other
hand there's a client or a patient who
has this medical report and wants to
learn the prognosis based on this
machine learning model but at the same
time he wants to not reveal his medical
report to the model owner and the model
owner wants to do this without ever
revealing the model to the client or the
patient
and this problem can be solved with
different kinds of privacy preserving
technologies and one of them is mpc or
secure multi-party computation which is
a cryptographic tool which comes with
strong security guarantees that at the
end of the protocol parties only learn
the output and output alone and nothing
else about the inputs of the other
parties
now
specialized protocols in mpc have been
designed for this problem of secure
inference it has gained a lot of
popularity and also developer friendly
usable tools have been developed
like cryptflow from msr itself
which can take tensorflow onyx model as
input and automatically output mpc
protocols for secure inference
these tools have been tested on wide
variety of neural networks like simple
cnns resnet50 on imagenet many models
from healthcare space
such as the one including super large
teraflop size models like unit 3d which
do automatic tumor segmentation from 3d
ct scans
so all in all this problem of privacy
preserving secure inference i think is
practical today with the kind of
technologies which have been developed
another problem which we keep hearing is
that of
more model validation
in which case let's say i'm a model i am
a person who has data
and i want to determine whether a model
provided by a vendor performs well on my
data
and this also falls into the umbrella of
privacy-preserving machine learning
because both the parties involved have
natural privacy requirements
and we have also done one such study
between the stanford university who has
the state-of-the-art model for detecting
14 lung diseases from test x-rays and
carrying labs in india who has the
patient x-rays from india
so this is just gives a flavor of what
is possible today with privacy prisma
technologies now coming to gaps and
limitations
while all i described like to you is
practical with mpc today it comes with
performance overheads
for example inference of one chest x-ray
takes up to 15 minutes
and this can be practical in some
applications and might not be like
acceptable in some other applications
and given these overheads for example
today end-to-end secure training using
mpc is not practical because think about
it if i am saying one image takes 15
minutes then 15 minutes times a million
images is a lot of minutes and soon gets
intractable
thank you vivia i i that's a great input
in terms of really what sensitive
applications we are looking for and
limitations
now i'll move on to
what are your thoughts uh based on your
experience and expertise
yeah so let me uh talk about the
uh a little bit about the data privacy
problem
that
you have computed the model let's say
you did some
statistics about data
and and
you're releasing the model you or you're
allowing others to have access to the
model for predictions in those scenarios
there are many attacks that show that an
adversary would be able to reconstruct
information about the
individual data records in the training
set
and uh so
the
definitions that we have for privacy
notably differential privacy
um
would guarantee that if you train a
model under this guarantee
although the model would allow
general
information about the population to be
re released but with uh limits the
amount of information that
could be leaked uh about the individual
data records so something which is very
promising here is that this is also the
goal of machine learning right so when
we are training machine learning
algorithm in general we want to extract
the general patterns we are not that
interested in the corner cases
um so this is very interesting it is
possible then that designing algorithms
which are privacy preserving and
accurate at this time but the challenge
is that the tools that we have now
would not allow us to do that for large
models
right so there's there's a gap between
what we think we could achieve with
certain level of privacy and what we are
achieving now
notably the issue is that our assessment
of the privacy risk
is is an overestimation of what privacy
risk we have for using an algorithm and
i think that the next steps would
involve
reducing that gap and having a better
estimation of privacy risk
thank you so i think uh what you're like
with respect to gaps and limitations
it's the
privacy risks in practice that we have
and what theoretical guarantees
or the tools that we have right now
provide and that's the gap that we
should look at uh mitigating
thank you
and
yeah all yeah i would really love to
hear your thoughts on what do you think
uh are the capabilities and limitations
that still remain with privacy
technologies thanks shruti um so i will
um
i guess more focus first on uh what uh
diva has said so i will focus on the
trust execution environment or ts
because i've had more experience working
with them certainly is aimed to
guarantee similar things that divia has
talked to doing training inference but
using a different technology so it's a
hardware or software capability
basically to provide isolation for for
your computation be it machine learning
or in signals from the rest of the
system from the operating system or from
other processes so it's quite
attractive when you want to
run something
on the cloud and use cloud resources so
here we have come actually a long way
since 2016 when i was at microsoft
research working on this and when we
actually ported some of the algorithms
in c to be able to run them on um on
intel sgx since then the techno it's
really
amazing how much this technology has
come now we have things like sjx and lkl
or graphene sjx that basically have a
way to uh run things like pie torch uh
or tensorflow basically on on these tts
um
there is um in terms of i guess um where
and and actually they are provided uh
as part of the cloud offerings at
microsoft google uh and ibm
different types of teas so then the
question is i guess what is um the i
guess the limitations we have all seen
kind of the
a lot of side channel attack papers in
the past five years there is i think
every conference has oh
every year there has been at least one
uh attack paper on one of the teas um so
but i don't think it is a limitation i
think it's an opportunity actually to
create open source designs for teas and
such as uh for example sanctum
or keystone for customizable teas why
because they will be can be verified by
the community because they're publicly
available or even amendable to formal
verification
what i do see is a gap is
when we want to talk about
privacy-preserving machine learning we
need to look at the end-to-end spectrum
so it's not just about performing the
computation securely we need to think
what this computation actually reveals
what the output reveals about the input
so consider a pathological example where
reading a stream encrypted and then i
output it in a reverse order even though
i did it on encrypted data the output
directly links the data and i think this
brings it to the point that reza was
trying to make is that
in order to guarantee we need um the
end-to-end privacy we need to guarantee
secure computation and consider how it
combines with privacy techniques for
example with differential privacy and
what i think is also a gap with
collaborative learning when we return an
output when the hospitals are trained in
a machine learning model for example can
one hospital determine the materiality
rate uh in another hospital's data but
just by merely getting the output that
was computed on on their data even if it
was done securely with any of the
techniques that for example divia
mentioned or tease
um and here
the question is how can we still
guarantee basically the ant to and
privacy in that setting and actually as
should in our work together with you and
veterans and we did show that a party
can learn a distribution for example
gender in another party's data and so on
so yeah i think we need to really
consider the end-to-end spectrum of in
order to guarantee privacy
thank you alia i think you've made some
uh great points there also connecting
the responses both from the via andresa
that each of these privacy technologies
that we know has some capabilities but
also limitations and maybe it's not just
individual technique that will give us
an end-to-end uh privacy preserving
machine learning setup but a combination
of two or more of these like
differential privacy you will need to
apply it even if you are using computing
on encrypted data or with trusted
execution
as at the end output and depending on
what it reveals
and again for efficiency maybe a
combination of using trusted execution
environments plus mpc
would be
suitable for some application settings
wherever that's desirable especially for
maybe secure training using teeth and
then secure inference using uh applied
cryptography
uh that's great
is there any other thing that you would
want to add or a last comment for
specifically uh discussion on this topic
i think my final comment would just be
that all these technologies bts mpc or
he and so on they just tell you um given
a function which you want to compute it
just tells you what's a secure way of
computing it and they can give you uh
security and performance trade-offs and
so on but i think one needs to really
think about
what outputs are safe to reveal and even
do you really want to reveal the output
so even they should remain hidden and
you just want to keep computing on
encrypted stuff
so that's i think a very important
question is to what outputs are safe to
reveal
and
whether you should do it
i agree i think that that's a very good
point just looking at interfaces
that will be exposed and then which
technology applies there
uh thank you devya
moving on to the next question which i
think
is in similar flavor but uh looking at a
more general problem for
the industry perspective which is of
data fragmentation that across
geological uh geopolitical boundaries
is it is making it more difficult to
assemble central training sets like data
is being generated across different uh
countries and there are different
privacy laws that are applied in each of
these so how can we actually use this
technologies to collect centralized
training sets and how can existing uh
techniques that we discussed or even
newer like federated learning or
collaborative learning that earlier you
mentioned can play a role in addressing
this challenge
oh yeah maybe because you've already
touched upon the collaborative learning
and multi-party setting you want to
start with
uh addressing
this question sure sure to thank you so
i think in order to answer this question
we really need to understand what the
policy relates to and whether the data
actually needs to be transferred so for
example when i'm
what do i mean about the policy is
whether policy relates to the data or
the information about the data that
needs to be
exchanged so what i can see is for
example in a local setting we have some
data and then there is a
central server so then the question is
of transferring the data from this local
server to the central server and whether
it is needed
so besides kind of the techniques that
we mentioned there are actually
technologies um of transferring of ways
to learn on the data without actually
having to transfer it so um one way is
federated learning as you mentioned
right where the data doesn't have to be
transferred we only compute some
gradients and help the central server to
aggregate the uh the gradients and
compute the model so that's one way the
second way is methods based uh like for
example patter framework where each
local kind of mod there can be local
models computed and then you just answer
for example to the server you label some
of the data or you answer some of the
central questions and help the model to
be computed so again in here we don't
transfer the data but we just introduce
some outputs of some computations or
some answers to questions
so that's one way the second way maybe
we actually
bring the model to the uh to the um
local
uh device so there are techniques
actually not in security but in machine
learning such as fine union right so we
can compute a general central model and
then send it
to the for example if it is uh
an uh model trained on english language
we can send it somewhere where it is a
different language with only thousands
of people speaking it and then train uh
train that
so but the key thing is is this versus
this technologies is that we do know
that even if we don't send the data we
still leak some information about it
right or not leak that we are learning
some information about it so
gradients reveal some information about
the membership or the properties right
the pre sent in the model is
mentioned
susceptible to membership attack so that
is why i think the key is to understand
in the whether the policies related to
information or data and then use the
technology towards yes so in that
great uh thank you earlier i think that
was a fantastic answer uh really giving
us the ideas but also what are the
limitations still and
with respect to really addressing these
policies
looking at does it apply to data model
and then looking at what defenses can be
used
thank you
divya
i would go to you next for looking at an
answer for this question
thanks
another great question so um i think
you're right that you know like these
regulations which are coming into place
more and more are trying to restrict and
define uh what data gets collected where
it is stored for how long and what
purposes it can be used for and so on i
think even then these policies are quite
primitive they just try to say some very
basic things that data should be kept
encrypted and cannot leave in the clear
and so on right so i think that these
technologies like mpc and uh computing
encrypted data and others can actually
be used uh to still derive benefits from
data uh
while ensuring that data in the clear
never leaves these geopolitical
boundaries for example things like only
encrypted data leaves the boundaries
so if i just to uh name technologies
like mpc they can be used to train on
encrypted data
when you can have the strong guarantees
that only the final model will be
revealed
and that too uh to the agreed upon
parties only and that can also be remain
hidden and so on but it does come with
again performance overheads you can do
this for um some commonly used models
like a logistic regression and small
dnns but performance degrades badly when
you go to large models and as olia
mentioned right that federated learning
is a technique which has been designed
to specifically solve
this problem you don't need to move the
data you don't need to uh
compute jointly you can just train your
models locally and then combine those
gradients but as she mentioned the issue
is that these gradients are getting
leaked right now the question is what do
the gradients reveal about the
underlying data itself
and then you can use techniques like
differential privacy on top of it
to these locally trained models and say
that it mitigates some of these attacks
but setting these like parameters of dp
gets increasingly challenging as the
function your computing gets more and
more complex right so there are these
various technologies which exist out
there uh which have their own trade-offs
uh but at the same time i feel that for
any of these technologies to be used in
practice some dialogue needs to happen
between the policy makers and the
technology creators to be able to
understand what is okay and what is not
okay
for example i think it's a case can be
made that it should be okay if only
encrypted data leaves the geopolitical
boundaries and the key never leaves
so uh and encrypt data without key is
essentially useless right like you
cannot decipher the individual data or
some such things have to come in place
right where the
law understands the technology and
technology understands the law and then
i think we can come up with the
innovative solutions for this problem
yeah that's a great response here i
think we we still need some synergy
between the laws and what are the
capabilities of technologies and like
there are some strong properties as you
said right without the key that you
can't really do anything with the data
you have to bring it back to the
country or the area where the key
resides so i think that that's a
great uh way to look at how can we
address these issues
um reza i would come to you for a
response for this question what are your
thoughts on
it so um i think olia and divya very
well um
showed the big picture where all these
technologies can come together to
preserve privacy
but uh what i want to add and rather
highlight or twofold one is
the threat models and the other one is
the settings in which decentralized
learning is used
so i've seen
many times that
the threat models are not well presented
and in many cases even federated
learning is presented and advertised as
a as a privacy preserving
mechanism which definitely is not
as pointed out before if you have
the simplest and uh
and the popular
algorithm for federated learning which
is repeated training and sharing the
gradients with the server to aggregate
and send back well the gradient vectors
are
very high dimensional the encoder a lot
of information about the local data and
and
eventually one would be able to
reconstruct all the
surprising information which is in the
in the local data right
which with violet data obviously so it's
very
important to know what is the threat
model um even if data doesn't
leave
the uh the the sensitive whether the
sensitive information is
could be inferred or not
and
the second thing is about the settings
in which we use decentralized learning
so
so all this started with very
simple
scenarios where everybody has more or
less the same type of data and everybody
has exactly the same objective
and there is a server that later on
could be replaced by te or uh secure
multi-party computation that just does
the aggregation
but but as soon as you
um change the data distribution a little
bit then we'll see that the models don't
converge to what we you know the the
comparison the case of
data being distributed beautifully in an
id way and as soon as you add privacy
protection mechanisms like differential
to private uh mechanisms then we are not
learning anything so for example if you
want to learn a language model over
multiple parties
and
gradients let's say are randomized at
the local level
we don't learn anything it doesn't
convert to anything useful in many cases
actually
uh even for the simpler tasks what we
learn with differentially private
federated learning is worse than what
you learn if you just train on your own
data
right so that is one thing that that we
we need to pay attention to and another
there are other aspects so for example
there is robustness of federated
learning when you add randomness
then
malicious parties can hide in the crowd
because
then their
malicious manipulation parameters would
be indistinguishable from the randomness
that ep would add right so that's
another challenge right i think
the more realistic scenarios um
are
way more challenging than the original
setting
when everybody would just share a model
in the same way yeah yeah thank you as i
think uh you made some really good
points about looking at the threat model
which is often uh
like the main reason where technologies
don't really give the guarantees that
they promise or the way they are being
applied it's just the threat model is
not right and federated learning looking
at it maybe opens up or solves some
problems but as you said like robustness
or gives more capabilities to users so
it is really important to look at
using this technology what are the pros
and cons and what is the desired uh
outcome from it with respect to both
privacy and security
thank you for these great points uh in
the interest of time i'll quickly move
on to our next question and just maybe
uh
a thought on what do you think uh
would be great for our audience and uh
people watching uh this video so from
the long term research perspective uh
what do you think would be directions
for research that should be given more
attention to improve both security and
privacy guarantees of ml models uh
because i think you already pointed out
some directions definitely uh would you
want to just go ahead
yeah absolutely uh so
one thing that i've always been
advocating or at least it's my interest
as well is that when you're talking
about privacy
um
we cannot have a privacy preserving
system
[Music]
if you don't have the right metrics and
tools to evaluate the privacy risk
and it is true that in the ideal world
we might have algorithms
and and and guarantees that privacy is
perfectly preserved accuracy is good
but in the realistic settings
we are far from that
so having uh a privacy auditing tool
would be something that that is i think
necessary
to have a way to measure arriving series
so we have been developing
a tool that we call a ml privacy meter
with exactly this objective that whether
in the centralized or in a feather
entering setting
if you want to know how much information
is leaked about your training data you
will be able to track that and that
actually could be helpful uh to evaluate
the
effective privacy loss that you have
even though if you have a provable
privacy guarantee as i mentioned the
privacy guarantees that we have for
differential privacy are usually
overestimations of the privacy laws
something that i want to
maybe clarify here is that differential
privacy talks about the worst case
privacy can a risk
of an algorithm
whereas in practice you have an instance
of that algorithm and then that instance
which is a model would leak
way less than the you know the worst
case would leak
uh in that
domain of that algorithm right so i
think it's always good to to have those
tools to to track the privacy laws yeah
thanks liza uh alya just quick thoughts
what do you think should we look at next
i think we might be moving away from
individual privacy whether someone for
example is positive to the virus or not
versus data set level privacy so if
someone reveals a computation in the
whole data set what are the properties
about the data set that are being
revealed and here in contrast to the
example about the attribute of someone
it's the property of the data set so the
distribution of how many people for
example are positive on a certain virus
so and differential privacy
unfortunately is not designed to protect
that so i think we need to move on to
this productivity level uh privacy uh
because even if some like in my data i
don't have that i am a female born in
the particular year just the ratio the
tick tock uh versus youtube videos that
i share probably will reveal um my age
so yeah this is what i think is moving
to the data set of level privacy
yeah yeah totally agree i think that's a
good point and uh divya uh what are your
thoughts
yeah so i think uh i'll say a couple of
things so first one as i already
mentioned was the dialogue between the
lawmakers and the technology makers
right which should really help advance
this area the second thing i feel is
this um the idea of co-design of machine
learning and privacy technologies would
really benefit the performance and other
things of privacy-preserving machine
learning technologies just to give an
example right that
on cpus the cost profile of all the
primitive operations is the same right
additions multiplications comparisons
everything costs the same but for things
like mpc editions are free
multiplications require parties to talk
comparison sigmoid etcetera are even
more expensive so
when we try to fit
custom-made ml algorithms to mpc or
other technologies though the
performance is very strange right we see
very counter-intuitive results as a
machine learning engineer so i think
core design of
ml and technology like this privacy
building technologies would really help
bridge this gap
and secondly i feel that we should
invest heavily into coming up with
better and stronger attacks against
machine learning so people start to care
about security and privacy when they
explicit attacks for example a sequence
of data breaches on on the data uh like
forced people to use encryption at rest
and soon it became a de facto standard
so if you really want people to care
about security and privacy of machine
learning uh we need to have explicit
attacks
uh and then uh we can get
and then we it can help us design
systems which protect against those
attacks if we don't know what we're
protecting against then all our models
are just very uh theoretical and in the
air
thanks thanks david i think uh yeah i
think motivating the search directions
both from attack and defenses uh that's
an excellent point that was a really
great discussion i would like to write
thank you all father members once again
for joining us at abisar research summit
and i i hope like the audience will
really enjoy watching this video when
it's out there on october 21st thank you
thank you
thank you so much
thank you thanks for having us